we've got um kalila my my girlfriend and
co-host beautiful as ever
and uh we've got me one of the one of
the ones
i'm one of the ones guys um i'd like to
start off by saying that
um big ed go [ __ ] yourself my friend
what happened what happened
hello hello um
so what happened was um so i'm a big fan
of um
90 day fiance and uh before the 90 days
and there's this gentleman by the name
of big ed that's on it and he's um
um on it with uh someone that closely
resembles somebody that we know
um juliana and uh in fact if that
doesn't work out i'm gonna
try to pimp out julian
she's the perfect age that's great
you're a matchmaker
she's the perfect she hasn't even had a
debut what's a dabu
dabu is like a cotillion when you turn
18. it's like a quinceanera but then
it's uh
you don't have it until you're 18. and
then in the filipino culture
um you you have 18 roses and 18 candles
right look at her she's so angry and at
your birthday party
at you're going to throw one for her no
no no she already turned 18.
um but um you have 18 candles and 18
roses
you have 18 guys you have to dance with
and then 18 girls that are part of your
like
cotillion party you're coming out party
don't get me wrong
i'm not ed the contract that we have
with ed
and and juliana is there's gonna be no
sex she's gonna be
stay a virgin for the rest of her life
okay don't you have your legs jules
yeah in fact i've i've created a
metallic hymen
i have a little workshop yeah yeah so
i've been you know constructing
yeah i have a little workshop i have a
little metallic hymen
that i go over her over her other hymen
yeah right so that it just no one's
gonna penetrate it the only one that
could is colossus may be from
um x-men x-men great ride six flags
yeah it's a great ride on six flags but
yeah there's no [ __ ] but see here's what
happened with ed big end
so i guess i've been making fun of him
you know saying that he has no neck
and he looks like a candle melting or
whatnot and i think that
you know i started the i started the war
he drew first blood i drew first blood
and then
he said i guess this is what i get from
um other tiger belly fans
that one of in one of his instagram
lives
he said that kalila was too hot for me
whoa low blow dvds
she told me that i was in a depression
for how long babe
i was pondering it for a couple hours
going this [ __ ] i'm gonna bring him
down i'm gonna destroy him or whatever
you know what goes through my mind
extort him for what no destroy him i
mean not extort him destroy him
you know i was like in my mind i was
like i was gonna set him up with like
this [ __ ] virgin girl that i have
living in my house and stuff
and whatnot but like now it's terrible i
know but
you you mind your own business okay so
and but
then in my head i'm like oh well i'm
gonna take that away from him
you know but um but then i realized that
i drew first blood
i called him a melting man i called him
a thick neck guy
he called him no neck necklace necklace
and then
um he so i started so you know what
let's
you know let's call it truce you know i
started the war
uh i would still love ed on tiger belly
that'd be nice
no i'm team rosemarie who are you i am
too
we're team rosemarie in this house no
because she i guess did a
instagram live where she said something
where oh yeah i saw that she said
something along the lines of like
he did this like solely for tv purposes
he's a liar like he never like don't
don't believe what he says like when
he's
allegedly like spent money on her yeah
she's like she he bought me bra
and panty and that's all yeah that's
what she said and then so i'm standing
rosemary
also she let that guy inside of her oh
that's so sad
you know what i mean what if he has what
if his dick is like his neck or just
known
stem it's just it's just like balls and
then just the head
that would be so weird so a literal [ __ ]
and when it gets hard just the head gets
bigger no gilb he's saying
that the balls are attached to the dick
so that upon entry the balls go in as
well
it probably looks like uh a mushroom
you mean like don't all penises look
like mushrooms yeah but the stem like
not even just a regular what is a
portobello or
portobello is very big and white yeah
yeah that's what it is but not too much
of a stem though
yeah no stem portobello i think you're
talking about oyster mushrooms
yeah mine is like that you know those
little japanese mushrooms
which one's oh the thin ones
that you put in yeah that's what mine
did yeah yeah yeah yeah little notes i
was gonna say porcini
but oh oh all right well i should uh
just flatten
maybe i'll upgrade upgrade my dick but
um
so also um i'm very sad right now
because
of the fact that i'm on i think i'm on
my last
mission on the witcher 3. you know i've
been
playing this game for a couple of weeks
all day
i know george you're interested but yeah
yeah but i really love the game i never
played it before
and uh i've upgraded all my i have all
the witcher gear
i've i've a grand master ursan armor
grand master wolven armor grand master
cat school armor
i have i've gone to every single
question mark on the [ __ ] maps